we have heard that a trader named
Davinder Singh sera was arrested in
London for manipulating us futures
markets prosecutors say that sir as
spoofing contributed to the May 2010
flash crash when the S&P 500 index fell
by about 6% in a matter of minutes
before quickly rebounded so what did Sir
Alec use that doing spoofing or layering
involves putting in fake electronic
orders on one side of the market and an
effort to move the price the spoofer who
wants to buy futures may put it in order
to sell a lot of them in just above the
current market price other traders who
see this spoofer zorder will think
people are dumping futures and will rush
to sell driving down the price of course
the spoofer sell order will never
execute and he'll start buying a few
contracts at the new lower price then he
can repeat the process and reverse
pretend he wants to buy a lot of futures
which will push the price up and let
them sell at a profit
prosecutors say that on the day of the
flash crash surrounded exactly that
netting about eight hundred thousand
dollars in profit in just that one day
but they also say that he did this many
more times over the five years since the
flash crash case you wonder why it took
so long for authorities to catch on